nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
i just left the walter reed medical
center
and i learned so much in coronavirus
don't be afraid of it
you're going to beat it we have the best
medical equipment don't
be afraid of it feel great like better
than i have in a long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're gonna beat
it we have to pour on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
and maybe i'm amused i don't know be
afraid of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life
be afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
afraid of it as your leader i had to do
that i knew there's danger do it but i
had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
is
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives we provided 48 million dollars to
fund the mayo clinic study that tested
the
efficacy of convalescent
all right welcome everybody um it's good
to have an opportunity to just sort of
get
caught up on stuff because there's so
much we've fallen behind on
the the big news is that we now have a
comprehensive report on so-called voter
fraud and there was none
that would have any impact on the
election if there were any attempts at
voter fraud
they seem to be almost exclusively on
the republican side but in either case
um we have a very very close to final
election results and i'm going to get to
a new new york times report on that very
soon
and the pressure is building on the
president to say i lost
and at this point unclear whether what
we will hear
from anybody from this administration
today
or who knows even when but the results
are are increasingly clear
the margin of victory now 5.15
million votes for joe biden georgia has
still not been called but it's mostly
mostly an academic exercise at this
point
as you know pennsylvania has been called
and arizona has been called michigan
uh south carol i'm sorry north carolina
um
not yet called by the associated press i
believe some have called it
um but it was never really part of part
of the equation
for uh donald trump uh um uh in other
words it was
it was almost a necessary part of the
equation for donald trump
it was not a part of once we saw the way
things were going on election night it
was not likely to be a part of joe
biden's eventual winning margin
which now sits at 290 to 217 but we are
still officially waiting for north
carolina and georgia
alaska has been called now in the midst
of
all of this coronavirus has exploded
and some of you might remember donald
trump said november 4th you'll never
hear about coronavirus again
everything will be open you know so on
and so forth and in fact we're seeing
the opposite we're seeing
seeing even red state governor say
everybody's got to wear a mask
we've got to start curfews we have to
start shutting things down utah's
republican governor saying
mask mandate fortunately we're getting
some leadership from joe biden on
coronavirus and
and they're try the trump administration
is trying to shut biden out to the
extent that they can
but he has a coronavirus task force it
has already met michael osterholm from
that coronavirus task force
has already said we may need a four to
six week shutdown
if we do it we will make sure
financially people are taken care of we
will spend money if we need to do it
we have the money but look at these
numbers 144
000 new cases yesterday nearly 1500
deaths and as you can see you know it's
crazy
when we were look at these numbers when
we were here
we thought this is insane 32
000 cases a day and then cases started
trickling down to about twenty thousand
and then we got here seventy thousand
cases a day and we said oh my god it's
insane
and then we got back down to about
thirty five thousand cases a day
and look at where we are right now and
as as far as deaths go the deaths are
spiking
we are now at a 9 11 every two days
and remember that these death numbers
are based on the case numbers
um from roughly october 20th 21st
if you go back to october 20th 21st
there were half the cases a day then
less than half
40 percent so simple math
suggests that within three weeks and
this
is i mean it it's horrifying within
three weeks we could be at a 911 every
single day
um where was it i think it was was it
here that donald trump said 15 cases
would soon be zero
i think it was right i don't remember if
that was middle to late march
or early april but somewhere during this
almost
parabolic ascent in terms of the death
toll
donald trump said 15 cases would would
soon be zero
mid-march it was okay fair so that's
what's going on as far as
uh coronavirus goes and you know now now
that we think back to
when fauci said you know guys if we're
not careful
um we could get to a hundred thousand
cases a day in the fall
and all of these lunatics said no that
would never happen
never never that would this guy's crazy
and fauci was too conservative
understand that
the crowds at trump's rallies were
chanting fire fouchy
and fouchy if anything was not alarmist
enough
about the situation now we have a lot of
hopes wrapped up
in the vaccine there are still questions
about the vaccine etc etc etc so we're
going to look at
some of the latest allegations from
prump
from trump jr from rudy giuliani
um i have memes i just have tons of
different stuff and then you know of
course
there is increased pressure for trump to
say something
and if it were to happen this would
typically be the time of day
where it would happen let me check the
latest uh trump schedule
um so so the reason that there's some
suspicion we may hear from trump is
at four o'clock trump had a meeting with
pompeo
and mnuchin or machuchin as one of my
viewers called him
um so if we are to hear from trump today
it would be yeah i know schedule right
the schedule is you sit at the white
house and you watch fox news actually no
it's not even fox news anymore now it's
newsmax and oan which i will also get to
i have new extremist voicemails to play
for you
uh but let's start with the voter fraud
and then i'm gonna go to super chats and
we're going to go to all sorts
i'm going to do recent firings i see
bing
and um who else
just all sorts of people are are telling
me to talk about the firings let's go in
order please let's take it piece by
piece first and foremost
no evidence of voter fraud okay it's
very easy
when things are crazy you look at donald
trump jr's tweets
and then you look at giuliani's podcast
and all of this different stuff
and it just sounds overwhelming like
they're alleging
fraud in pennsylvania they're saying
people
uh had envelopes full of fraud in
michigan
you know all this different stuff you
have to really step back
the the new york times called officials
in every state no evidence of voter
fraud
the president and his allies have basis
baselessly claimed that rampant voter
fraud stole victory from him
officials contacted by the times said
there were no irregularities that
affected the outcome
this means you call republican and
democratic secretaries of state
this means you call republican and
democratic you know deputy secretary
we're talking about this is not a
partisan thing election officials in
dozens of states representing both
political parties said there was no
evidence that fraud or other
irregularities played a role in the
outcome of the presidential
race amounting to a forceful rebuke of
president trump's portrait of a
fraudulent election
over the last several days the president
members of his administration
congressional republicans and right-wing
allies
have put forth the false claim that the
election was stolen from mr trump
and have refused to accept results that
showed joseph r biden jr as the winner
but top some people ridiculed me by the
way for referring to him as joseph r
biden jr now everybody's doing it
it was weird i had somebody say they
were they found it pretentious when i
would say it and they were no longer
going to watch streams
and now everybody's saying joseph r
biden jr
top election officials across the
country said in interviews and
statements that the process had been a
remarkable success despite record
turnout
and the complications of a dangerous
pandemic
um other relevant questions i mean you
know they have anecdotes
kansas didn't experience it minnesota
doesn't know of a single case
ohio secretary of state said the
conspiracy theories and rumors are
running rampant but it's mythology
etc etc state now this is interesting
statewide officials in texas did not
respond to repeated inquiries but a
spokeswoman for the top elections
official in harris county
the largest county in texas with a
population greater than many states said
there were only a few minor issues and
we had a very seamless election
i do think it's worth mentioning that
when you have a hundred and what is it
160 million votes cast
of course you are going to have
anecdotal allegations of a lot of stuff
there may well be even here we go now
there may even be
dozens of instances of someone who sent
an absentee ballot
and then died by election day or a
double registration
but it would not even come close to
making a difference
in any state that's the important thing
because then when we
when we say there were there was not
even a single instance of
accidental anything then they say well
look at this person
a supposed 122 year old voted in
wisconsin or you know some
some random thing the question is would
it make any difference
in even a single uh county never
mind state and the answer is of course
no
no it would not um some states described
small problems
common to all elections which they said
they were addressing
a few instances of illegal or double
voting oh this is i should have just
read it it's literally what i'm saying
some technical glitches some minor
errors in math officials in all states
are conducting their own review of the
voting
a standard component of the
certification process
so this is the big headline no evidence
of voter fraud relevant to the results
in any state oh
um oh [ __ ] so we enabled nightbot
and i wonder if nightbot is going a
little too crazy it's just been turned
on i have not tweaked any of it right
now
and if nightbot is going crazy i
apologize moderators please
you know let me know what we need to
change i don't even know what's going on
uh it's just been turned on and it's
going need to change spam filters okay
we'll deal with that after guys because
there's
there's a lot going on okay let me read
a few super chats then i'm gonna get to
the trump firings which are very
very important um let me go to the top
pat says while everyone's watching
trump's diversion of voter fraud anyone
paying attention to how he is giving
away the store
arms deals with other nefarious
countries
recent firings are the most important
topic chakaseki says
corey flewandowski tested positive for
the china plague
what is more ignominious than losing an
election getting infected by a virus
you deny have you seen that trump sketch
where he's being removed from the white
house and is ruling you
yelling you can't replace me what about
me you can't do this to me i have not
seen it
alexander says according to a tweet
congressman ted liu retweeted trump
advisers in a
zoom call talked about faithless
electors so my question is do you think
faithless electors will help trump win
so i would not be shocked if there are
some faithless electors i do not believe
there will be 20 or 36 which by the time
this is all said and done
would be the number you need to overturn
the election there were two faithless
electors in 2016.
trump earned 306 electoral votes there
were two faithless electors
we thought maybe there would be eight or
ten there were two and he ended up with
304
but it was not enough to overturn the
results i don't believe it will be
enough to overturn the results this time
chris says david hire jenk for your show
he's great
i don't know if you guys understand but
like we have four employees and
tyt has like 70. if anybody's hiring
anybody it would be jank hiring me
um but but i'm perfectly happy on my own
show but i think i don't know uh
uh the the the power dynamics are a bit
upside down there i don't think it would
be us who
who would be hiring jenk but i i like
the idea i like the idea
okay let's now go to the firings okay
this
is also a massive massive story trump's
firings at the pentagon put our national
security at risk
over the past few days president trump
has fired four of the top officials in
the pentagon
secretary of defense mark esper under
secretary of defense for policy
the under secretary of defense for
intelligence and the chief of staff
to the secretary of defense in essence
he has
military term alert decapitated our
operational civilian leadership of the
military
high fives are likely happening from
beijing to moscow to caracas
it appears to be a simple act of
vengeance against the team trump felt
did not support him in the run-up to
election
to the election in their place he has
installed a largely unknown group
of political sycophants who have neither
the stature nor the experience
to undertake these jobs each of which is
vital to our national security
some americans may simply shrug it off
and say oh that's just trump being trump
but having served two years a senior
military assistant to the sec deaf
as a three-star vice admiral i can
assure you it matters
these moves diminish our national
security markedly over the next couple
of months
until the new biden administration takes
over why does it matter so
much and the the author who is james
stavridis goes on to explain read the
article but i actually have
have sort of a bigger red alert to sound
for you
understand if you're a foreign power
right now
or if you're an adversary or if you're
an enemy
or if you're a terrorist group right now
okay
we've known that for a long time donald
trump has gotten very bored during his
presidential daily briefings
uh they've reduced it to a single page
often the page
is like very few it's a couple bullet
points and then some pictures
like charts or graphs even reduced to
that
um in the back of the room there's often
a tv with fox news now it would be like
oan or newsmax
and very often even during the briefing
that's a page
with pictures trump would get distracted
and look to the back of the room so as a
general thing
if you're a terrorist group you know
trump is not really on the ball but
maybe
in in the pentagon they're on the ball
you now have a situation
think about this i mean really trump
doesn't pay attention he's not even
getting his pdbs anymore
he's fired people at the pentagon and
brought in sycophants who are completely
in over their head
and because trump is denying the sort of
formal
transition process it won't prevent
biden from being president but it is
preventing biden from getting the pdbs
even some republican senators have now
said biden should be getting pdbs
if you're a terrorist group you're
thinking there is a two-month period
here
during which no president is getting the
pdbs
and the pentagon is run by unqualified
sycophants
it's a national security risk it's a
massive
national security risk i i you know i
see
some people wrote to me and said david
you shouldn't mention it you you might
be inviting
listen guys the terrorists know it i'm
not inviting anything it's not me who's
giving people ideas here
it's a national security disaster and
you're right people who are sending
super chats saying
it's made even worse by the fact that
now there are sycophants
nobody is getting p the president's not
getting the pdbs
the president-elect's not getting the
pdbs the pentagon is being run by
by unqualified sycophants it's a
disaster so
let's try to get past this period let's
see if we can we can win these two
senate races
in georgia um but it is it is an
absolute and
complete disaster let me say a few thank
yous
okay dan rouhane has made a pledge on
patreon blake buzza
has signed up at joinpakman.com vicky
alloy
has signed up renee thomasell has signed
up and john reagan
has signed up that puts us at five new
members on my website
we are now new policy we are counting
twitch subs
and there have been nine of those which
puts us at 14.
uh okay what so let's let me start i
i always come prepared we've done no
evidence of
fraud we've done pentagon
is uh in in danger oh okay let me do
this and then we'll move on to a couple
of other things
peter allen i'm going to talk about this
tomorrow peter alexander
from nbc you know we've been wondering
is trump does trump really think he can
win
peter alexander tweeted this morning
trump is very aware there is not a path
to victory
but he believes the 72 million who voted
for him deserve a fight
so he's battling as a form of theater
for them
a top white house aide tells me so
understand the immorality of this
trump is claiming that he has a path to
victory but that he needs your money he
needs to fund recounts he needs to
fund all of this different horseshit
half of if you look at the fine print
half of the money he raises is not going
to any recount
it's going to paying off his campaign
debt there are
um trumpists on
uh fixed incomes there are trumpists who
are poor who are donating money because
they think trump
might actually be able to win if they do
trump doesn't even think he might be
able to win
if they donate money it's disgusting and
so this is not about
um this is not about you know uh
we we need a nanny state to protect
these people no no
it's not that we need government to
protect these people government is the
government is the perpetrator it's trump
who is scamming these people despite
knowing that there is absolutely no path
to victory
privately trump is reportedly thinking
about running in 2024. he seems to be
done
he seems to be done with this and it has
worked look at these look at these
numbers
let me zoom this out a little bit hold
on this is not framed properly for you
guys
would you say that joe biden
legitimately won the election
86 of trump voters do
not believe joe biden legitimately won
so
trump now knows that at least he's not
going to get a second term
he's convinced 86
of his voters that biden didn't
legitimately win
uh 80 percent of his voters
don't think trump should concede and
then look at this
a full uh hold on wait a second
am i looking at this right trump voters
okay yeah um
60 of trump voters believe
that what donald trump is doing will
reverse the results okay
how many people voted for this guy was
72 million
36 no 40 million voters in this country
believe that in the next two months
trump will end up getting inaugurated to
a second term
how do you fight that we're talking
about you know
needing like mass uh
deprogramming that i i'm not aware of
social psychology as a field
understanding how to do
you know you couldn't de-program 900
people
uh at jim jones's uh
you know out of jonestown or whatever
they called it down in uh
in guyana there how do you deprogram 60
million people how do you deprogram 40
million people whatever the number is
it's absolutely insane um and so so the
point is
even trump doesn't believe it at this
point uh but his viewers
uh his many of his voters do which is
just crazy
um okay let me look at a couple of other
super chats and then i
i do have a lot of other things to get
to alec vanderpull says i just wrapped
up watching the regular show and the
bonus show and immediately see your
streaming powerfully seamless parkman
experience today
love it chakaseki says the orange goose
has spoken
anyone up for some crappy kfc flavored
foie gras
i don't know what that's about d-pat
says david i like your
coupon code coo i like that that's nice
uh these are super chats via youtube i
wonder how many people got the virus
from voting in person
fair question recent firings i've
discussed
trump wins the states of hysteria denial
and lunacy
the state of embarrassment got goes to
the u.s citizens with more than four
brain cells yeah
oh let me let's listen to this this is
oh this is doug collins take a look at
this challenge is it
well i think it's going to give us an
opportunity to begin that we don't know
at this point especially with some of
the concerns that have been raised
nbc news now so that's doug collins he's
continuing to pretend
like these recounts might reverse the
results uh
and he's talking i think he's talking
about georgia by the way which is not
even necessary
biden doesn't even need georgia at this
point it's bizarre what's going on fox
business urgent fox business yeah
um okay do you guys want to hear a
couple
of voicemails the voicemails from the
sycophants have continued to come in
i'll play a couple of them
um i haven't un so earlier in the week
i played to you a jimmy from philly
voicemail from november 4th
where he was like you know all hopped up
and then a jimmy from philly voicemail
from november 6th and in the november
6th voicemail he was almost despondent
he left a voicemail on november 10th
it's only 19 seconds i've not
pre-screened it so i do want to want to
warn you guys
i don't know what to expect but let's
take a listen david
jimmy from philly what a
biden is not the president-elect
b it's true that this is this is
contested election c trump will win
oh boy um okay now what does he say at
the beginning there does he say
jimmy from philly white is he telling us
his race let me listen to that
jimmy from philly white hey
does anybody know what he's saying is he
is he announcing his race
i don't know what that is that's bizarre
white wiped what would wiped mean like
he wiped before
calling that would be strange thing to
announce
okay um all right and then i've got a
couple other voicemails for you guys
here
okay i've got the san antonio troll
this guy's specialty is calling in to
argue with me about things i've never
discussed he calls in to tell me i'm
wrong about things i've never talked
about
again this is pretty this is not
pre-screened let's take a listen
pac-man what is good what is good what
is
good i have well i'm not gonna say it
but i have a really nice
for the nickname you have given me i
have a really nice wwe
style thing but i'm not going to do it
because i know you wouldn't play it
but here's the thing i wanted to call a
really important issue
so i think that progressives i think the
problem with you guys
is that i mean by and large why america
rejects progressive ideas which is why
bernie got destroyed
destroyed in the primaries twice and
this second time worse than last america
will never be socialist america will
never be depressed
tell you why progressives want to bite
it's weird because like progressive
ideas are very popular
uh we i mean listen it's like
biden won the popular vote easily if you
want to talk about popularity
it's literally in the term popular vote
biden won by 5.1 million vote votes
um and you you know you have these
anti-democratic
systems like the senate wyoming gets two
senators guys
right wyoming has 500 000 people they
get two senators
california has 40 million people they
get two senators it's fundamentally
undemocratic
the senators representing just 17
percent of the american population could
unilaterally
acquit donald trump uh on impeachment
um then you've got um gerrymandering
and the urban rural divide which at a
systemic level favors
republicans then you have the electoral
college which favors republicans
you understand what i'm saying so anyway
the idea of popular seems like the right
the wrong way to go
the moderate i'm cool with bike i'm
actually okay with him the only thing i
didn't really like is gun policies
otherwise
he's not that bad um he's very very
republican like almost and i'm not even
a [ __ ] vote but
the reason progressives are very
authoritarian in their policies and
what's interesting is they don't they're
authoritarian to others but not
themselves
so you think uh sort of like uh we're
for small government unless you're
gay then we need the government to ban
that unless you want an abortion that we
need
the government to ban that unless you
know i mean come on god these
these are so maybe i you know i would
imagine this is a 17 year old except
he's been calling me for like a decade
example the worker co-op thing how
you're you you won't work for co-ops
everywhere but for your own companies i
don't work our co-op you just okay there
we go
uh so this is where we know so i'm gonna
end it here this is where he gets into
things i've
i've never said i want to
authoritarianly install work or co-ops
in fact i'm not a socialist i've said
one of the things i
that makes me not a socialist is i would
never
say i want the government to impose
that businesses must be worker co-ops
like cr people
socialists criticize me for that but
don't then accuse me of wanting that
i've made clear i don't want that so
anyway that's this guy's specialty
criticizing me for things i've never
actually said
um then we have troy york continuing to
call in
i guess we'll listen to one more of the
troy york ones
david pakman a man who has committed a
sinister plot
election rigging such as joe biden and
his political party
or and where he even tells everyone that
he has organized the biggest election
thought system there is
troy york's particularly incoherent
today so we probably won't get through
all of this
it's not going to get into white house
you can talk about him not being rattled
make all these videos of him not
laughing off trump's assertions but the
fact is
inside it's eating joe biden
he's not going to be in the white house
january 20th the american people realize
and are spreading the news
despite the the it's interesting
two of our of our regular trumpest
callers
in the last day have called in to say
biden will not be president so when i
showed you that poll which said
60 of trump voters believe ultimately
trump will be re-elected
we're seeing it on our voicemail lines
so it's absolutely and completely true
um okay oh let's listen to this this is
important republicans breaking with
trump prepare for
uh the transition here
um i would think especially on
on the classified briefing
the answer is should be getting security
briefing
so joe biden was getting those briefings
until the election was over
they stopped and i don't think it's i
think it's important that
both continue to get those briefings
until
the electoral college makes its final
determination
we still don't know who the president's
going to be and so we should be in the
same posture that we were in throughout
the whole campaign with both of them
receiving briefings okay so at least
he's saying biden should get the
briefing but what does he mean we don't
know who the president's ultimately
going to be we do know
uh we do know guys i i understand that
nightbot is pretty aggressive
in both youtube and and twitch this is
our first
time using it i am going to make a
request for both youtube and twitch uh
moderators
if if the ones who are really familiar
with nightbot if you guys want to email
me
after the stream i will look at exactly
which settings need to be
tweaked and i will gladly do that i'm
aware
we're just starting to use uh nightbot
and and it's going to need to be tweaked
okay a few other super chats from folks
uh chakaseki says someone on twitter
called mike pompeo
a pant loaf no finer decision
description of him
exists nice sam says there's a new
update about the pennsylvania lawsuit
secretary of state lacked authority to
change deadline two days before
election day uh okay i'll look into that
uh i'm unaware of that ep says
i'm in arizona got a call asking me to
confirm i was the one who actually cast
the ballot in my name they are
desperately looking for evidence they
are
jorah monathan says let's talk about the
deal real issue dp did you get your
daily dose of vitamin d today
yes i did although it was kind of uh
kind of uh
uh cloudy when are you chatting with
vaush
so listen i actually um so i already
interviewed vaush yesterday or vaash
and we published a little clip of it
already in fact let me see where it is
um hold on instagram
i think we might have published this to
instagram the inner the full interview
with
vosh is publishing tomorrow it's a half
hour interview i think many of you will
find it super interesting
but let me see if i have the clip here
hold on
hey uh this is absolutely nuts i i don't
want to spend a ton of time on
no hold on so where is it i don't even
know what
geez uh let me figure out
i want to give you guys a little bit of
a clip of vosh
it's actually it's it's pretty it's
funny there's a lot of funny stuff in it
let me just see if i can do it
uh where is the vosh interview i'm going
now
into the shareable link
okay i'll give you guys just a little
bit of the vosh interview
just to see if you guys have some sense
of it i'm going to get you this last
question this last question to wash was
really interesting but we're going to
you're going to have to wait until
tomorrow for the whole thing take a
listen that's that's we
we agree we definitely are agreeing on
more than i imagined maybe this is the
where we could end it do you think an
open-faced omelet
is a pizza where do you come down on
that i am
i am a um culinary and linguistic
descriptivist i think that if you want
to call it a pizza you have to and i
will respect your right to do so
so an open face omelette you're fine
calling a pizza absolutely
wow 100 that's huge that's huge and if
you put a tortilla under it then it's
absolutely a pizza right
oh oh i mean that just i mean that
nail's at home not that it needed
that affirmation but okay anyway so
we've got that and that's going to be
that's all going to be happening and
it's extremely extremely hard-hitting
interview as you can all
imagine okay good um i have a million
more things to get to
so let me just uh get an update
from the standpoint of members uh okay
we were at
four now we're at eight so that's an
additional four that puts us at
18 24 93 on twitch is plus nine that's
27. perfect
that's a perfect number uh okay
all right let me read a few other super
chats then i want to get to a few other
things here
um stewart says can you do televangelist
copeland's fake laugh
yeah we can look at that i know that i
never got to it um here's just a tweet
from don jr then i'll use this window
with so many irregularities for
americans to ever have faith in our
systems we need full audits everywhere
michigan republican party state senators
are requesting a full audit of the 2020
general election these people are
delusional you know it's like it barely
even makes sense to uh
engage with it kenneth copeland laugh
videos so this is televangelist kenneth
copeland
he has made i think it's like either 300
million or
700 million um bamboozling people he has
a very bizarre appearance
and he i guess tried to laugh
off the idea that joe biden will be the
next president all right take a listen
to this
the media said what ha ha
the media said joe biden's present
by the way this guy really disturbs me
every time i see this video this guy's
laugh
it seems like he's five percent
skeptical
where he's kind of doing it but but he's
like i don't know about this
this might be a little too weird
then people start standing which is just
lunacy
his mouth seems to unhinge at the jaw in
a way that's
that's weird
anyway so uh so that's that um
coveted numbers everybody's saying
hospitalizations are still low
they're not here was the peak
hospitalization level during
spike one peak hospitalization level
during spike two
and we are there we are there and we are
climbing and it's it's going to
it's going to be even further this is
data from the coveted tracking project
i would suggest following them on
twitter really really good
um oh okay i do want to deal with this
tweet donald trump
test uh tweeted two different things
today i think it's two things
yeah otherwise it's retweets trump is
now going after fox news
tweeting fox news daytime ratings have
completely collapsed
weekend daytime even worse very sad to
watch this happen but they forgot what
made them successful what got them there
they forgot the golden goose i guess
that means trump
the biggest difference between the 2016
election and 2020
was fox news so trump now going after
them
suspicions are trump wants to launch his
own competing
platform and then this is just crazy
report
dominion deleted 2.7 imagine
deleted 2.7 million trump votes
nationwide data analysis finds 221 000
pennsylvania votes
switched from trump to biden 941
000 trump votes deleted states using
dominion voting systems switched 435 000
votes from trump to biden
and and look who it comes from chanel
rion
at oan and of course uh this claim
about election fraud is disputed voter
fraud of any kind is exceedingly
rare in the us election experts confirm
uh it's pathetic the the world is
laughing at us and we covered today on
the broadcast show
how increasingly world leaders are just
done with trump they're moving on
here is one example i don't know why the
hell this video is so
look at how little this is i have no
clue why it's so little
this is um this is uh
this is lou dobbs on fox business okay
interviewing this is exclusive
okay this is one of the voter fraud
um people
who has devastating evidence of voter
fraud
she can barely put together a coherent
thought okay take a look at this
so they're um so i worked a 24-hour
shift
um i started at 6am and i got off at 6pm
or 6am uh the next day this this video
is incredible yeah
um so i started at six a.m
november third okay so we've so far
we've established
when she worked good got off at 6
00 am november 4th and actually i would
rather her adjust it for time zone 2
because that might have been 7 am on the
east we don't know
so i was there during their day shift
and their night shift
the city provides the workers with
food for their shift well they only had
enough food for
one-third whoa hold on a second
hold on a second there wasn't enough
food
all right go on of their workers
i'm sorry so that is the reason why
they were claiming that these vans were
were
brought in but these vans did not have
food it's
taken out of them supposedly they didn't
even have a kosher option in fact
is what i read not even they didn't have
kosher they didn't have
asian vegetarian they lacked a bland
meal which at this point every airline
offers a bland meal this place doesn't
even offer the bland meal it's crazy
and the vans the vans that showed up uh
they were supposed to be filled with
food not only that i read that the vans
are
supposed to be filled with 93 octane
gasoline
workers were reportedly seen going cheap
and
filling the vans up with 89 octane
gasoline too
did they have in them do you know
i never saw anything being brought
out of the vans i know that whatever was
being
brought out of the vans was being
brought out of the back of the vans
but right i was not allowed over in that
area
so essentially she saw nothing
other we so
i i really need you guys to understand
that when kaylee morgan annie
holds up stacks of affidavits okay
an example affidavit would be like this
woman's story
okay she saw vans she was not allowed
near the van
and there was not enough food for the
poll workers
that's an affidavit okay that's one of
the affidavits that they're saying
i guess is proof of some kind of voter
fraud
it's uh it's it's crazy it's it really
doesn't doesn't make any sense
um so anyway that's your uh that's
that's your that's your voter fraud uh
there that's that's the latest okay let
me get to some other messages
a slip and shank via twitch says keep it
up david love the content
tulmu says thanks for the streams and
the laughs can you imagine
i know um other twitch messages
thanks to deeper shades of house for
gifting
five tier one community sub gifts
oh wait a second deeper shades of house
deeper shades of house
uh i think i know who this is
yeah oh deeper shades of house is our
friend uh lars
baron roth um
major dj and we are considering license
by the way speaking of lars we are
the entire edm community
by the way is considering i have
something special for you guys
they are considering licensing so this
is a joke by the way
last time i mentioned this some people
thought it was for real uh the edm
community is fighting over licensing
rights
for remixes on some of the remixes we
have i have a new one this is from
max h music okay this is a
re-imagination of the david pakman show
theme
song and it is perfect okay take a
listen to this
i don't even know if this is legal yeah
here's something interesting today's
episode is sponsored by
we have so much to cover today that i
will not waste
any time we have so much to cover today
that i will not
waste any time
anyway yeah that's uh that i'm gonna
submit that as the possible theme song
for the next version of the video game
portal i think that that would be
absolutely perfect
and then um hold on i have something
else here too
let me take a look at this what's this
we'll get re-elected she then starts
speaking in tongues
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
until you have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you okay so that led to this
victory victory victory history history
history
anyway so that's that's uh that's pretty
powerful
and then just what just the last thing
on this
paula white thing there's a new angle
that's been released
from the paula white event and
i don't know if you guys saw who was in
the back there
but look at that it's me i was the guy
walking behind her
isn't that crazy with my biden 2020
shirt this is a sort of a more portly
version of me for sure
but it was really a magical magical
event so that was really good
all right guys that's that's that's a
lot uh
a lot of different stuff there so i
would like to
hear from yeah i need to lay off this
david snackman is more like it am i
right um
okay very good let me get to oh
people are asking oh yeah people are
asking about the facebook demonetization
i don't have any update on that so i
yesterday we did a story
we have been 100 demonetized on facebook
which is crazy because oh my pen just
exploded sorry
we have previously been 98 demonetized
on youtube but never 100
we are now 100 demonetized on facebook
and nothing has changed as far as that
goes we're still at 100 demonetization
and a bunch of our my viewers said hey i
have a contact at facebook we're gonna
try to figure something out and get you
in there
um and uh i so far nothing nothing else
has
has been uh said about that but this is
a beautiful time to say
this is why you know i'm not joking when
i say
our youtube revenue could disappear
twitch revenue could disappear facebook
revenue could disappear sign up at
joinpacman.com we have a coupon code
fresh start it saves you 70 percent
join pacman.com you sign up
they can't stop us we have control uh
five more people
just did sign up on my website which
puts us at
32 and then from the standpoint of
twitch
we are at 2500 twitch subs on the dot
that's seven
more we've never been at 2500 subs in
fact our previous
high was 1500 so let me see 2500 minus
1500 2 minus 1 is 1.
5 minus 5 is 0. 0 minus 0 is 0.
zero minus zero is zero that's a
thousand subscribers
on twitch more than we've ever
had which is just shocking
shocking stuff okay um
let me do a few other super chats and i
have a couple of other things
and then i would i would uh phone calls
um
you know i don't know about phone maybe
phone calls uh
maybe if we hit our goal we'll do some
phone calls tiffany says i'm unemployed
but want to join so bad as soon as i get
my life back i'll be
a member thank you for keeping me sane
thank you tiffany
uh norwegian trad archer says i wounder
are trump sue that states he won in or
is it only the one he lost
trump is only filing lawsuits in states
he lost that is true
yeah mass
says langhofer a lawyer for the trump
campaign this is not a fraud case we are
not alleging fraud
we are not saying anyone is trying to
steal the election
rather he's saying there were good faith
errors in the count okay that's a little
more realistic
hanan aslam says what are trump's
chances of winning in 2024
they're more than zero they're certainly
more than zero i won't lie
chris says jenk could make you the next
aoc
think about it oh my god charles says
what will relations with iran look like
under abiden presidency iran won't trust
us again a future republican
administration will erase any progress
that was made
yeah that's a real concern we're going
to do a bunch of foreign policy stuff
next week
if i'm iran obviously i want biden to
get back into the deal with me but i
also am aware of the fact that the next
guy or gal might just
cancel it and that is certainly
something that
i don't know how we deal with because
we've lost credibility
is trump trying to remove evidence in
the pentagon
you'd have to tell me evidence of what
um annunziata says do you think the
biden administration will have to
address
trump and his corona superspreader
events once biden begins his presidency
no i mean it'll they'll be over i'm not
sure maybe i don't understand but i
don't think so
gordon says glad you were here to help
us focus on the numbers as you mentioned
earlier we have a serious problem in our
country keep up the good work
pennsylvania court rules in favor of
trump let's look at that
pennsylvania court rules in favor of
trump since a couple people mentioned
that
so this is from an hour ago let's take a
look
at what they had to say
pennsylvania judge rules in favor of
trump campaign orders state can't count
some ballots
pennsylvania state judge ruled thursday
in favor of the trump campaign ordered
the state not to count some mail-in
ballots missing proof of id
and cured during an extended deadline
the ruling will not change the vote
count as it currently stands and will
not impact joe biden's win in the state
all right done very good yeah uh there
were
those were arguments about votes not yet
counted important to understand
um okay
don says once the pardons begin will
people start to realize he doesn't think
he won
yes i think so i think so
loki says so since trump is basically
leaving the country open to attack can
we not charge him
with treason or is it time to rise up
and overthrow him
he's leaving in nine weeks guys that's
what's happening he's leaving in nine
weeks
thomas says g'day from australia you
should take a look at the garbage coming
out of sky news australia constantly
spewing
coveted denial saying trump won we did
look at it on a recent stream it's
insane what's coming out of uh sky news
and justin says david when you say the
word fraud
your boston accent is very strong yeah i
don't have a boston accent
when i say fraud i'm sort of doing the
trump accent
but uh i did not grow up in boston
in you know interestingly people my age
there's much more of a
of a sort of class element for young
folks in terms of the boston accent it's
actually a really interesting topic to
study
um but i did not even grow up in boston
so it becomes irrelevant
t says hi dave i'm not going to fall for
that but t
says dave first time long time do you
tailor your button-down shirts or wear
them off the rack some days
you're practically swimming in your
shirt beef up
that's a very private question on all on
all fronts i'm not gonna
that would be more for like my s my only
fans or something like that
what do you think of the increases in
support for trump among minorities and
lgbt people is this something we should
be worried about we should and i've
talked about that and i'm talking about
it on my spanish show this week
as far as latino voters are concerned it
is something we should be worried about
what's the deal with florida voting
overwhelmingly for higher minimum wage
but voting for trump it doesn't make
sense
it doesn't it doesn't and maybe we'll do
a deep dive on florida at some point
soon
um will i cover biden's bite a gun
control plan
sure you can't get through
you can get through to trump as i did so
with my father before he passed he
became a bernie supporter
that's interesting let's bet he resigns
before december 20th
what's your favorite regional accent
um i don't know i don't think i have a
favorite regional accent
how do you sleep at night offering that
coupon code it's truly disgusting yeah
it really is it's a vile coupon code
it's vile um but it may not be around
for long so in all seriousness
grab yourselves a membership i want to
thank
eight additional people who just signed
up at joinpacman.com
putting us at 47 and uh oh dear god
we've lost
subscribers on twitch there must be
monthly subscribers expiring at this
point
because that is really really weird um
okay
other things i had uh oh oh okay
yeah let's do this so rudy giuliani has
a podcast
he just put out another episode of this
podcast let's let's look at a little bit
of it because this is from the last 24
hours i just want to see what um
what what's his new argument that he's
making let's take a listen
hello this is rudy giuliani and i'm back
with
rudy's common sense today he seems to
have two tablets going
we're going to take a look with common
sense oh
and what remains of the ballot counting
because this election is much closer
than any of the networks have you guys
noticed that rudy's head
often seems half shaved i don't know if
he cuts his own hair
but see how it's very very short here
and it's it's two or three times as long
on this side of his head i've noticed
this before
often also his left eye is almost
completely swollen shut
his lips are white which i think may be
a makeup thing
and his glasses are often crooked it's a
very bizarre look it's a very bizarre
look let's take a listen led you to
believe
last wednesday and uh
it is not determined yet and there is a
path
to victory for the president a path to
re-election
it's not uh an easy pass it's not a
definite path
but it's a realistic path what and
having called this election so early
the big media big tech didn't it take
longer than ever to call the election
other than the 2020 2000 florida recount
what does it mean
that was called quickly it took
five days for it to be called i don't
remember any time it was called
so slowly other than the fiasco in the
year 2000
weird and the democrat party is trying
to cut that off
and they're trying to cut off any
consideration of it which is outrageous
since they took over a month
to allow al gore to contest just one
state
here there are a number of states well
one of the differences was with al gore
there was evidence
and a significant amount of evidence of
rampant fraud
fraud thanks for the raid by the way
book smarts
all they say on television is there's no
evidence of fraud
i'm going to now show you lots of
evidence of fraud he has papers too
there's one thing for certain about this
election
not certain who want it it's certain
that this was the most
dirty the most fraudulently conducted
election
on the part of the democrats than any in
recent history
okay and we're going to show you just
why and we're going to begin
by concentrating on
two states the state of pennsylvania
and the state of michigan we're going to
concentrate on those too because
that's where we've been able to
concentrate our investigation originally
and the evidence
in both states his lips do seem bleached
i think what's more likely going on is
he's wearing
improperly shaded makeup on his entire
face and it's making the lips look light
by comparison
is overwhelming so in the state of
pennsylvania
what you basically had pennsylvania have
is a lawsuit now filed federal lawsuit
seeking to disqualify the votes
that were not properly observed in fact
that weren't observed at all
mailing votes are inherently
uh suspicious untrue what i mean
they are unreliable not me talking
this is the supreme court warning us way
back
oh manila folder um tell me the folder's
completely empty guys back in 2004
in a case called griffin against ruges
justice
suiter rufus announced that
mail and votes are less reliable than
in-person votes
voting fraud is a serious problem you
know the interesting thing about that is
the word less reliable is applied by the
supreme court 20 years ago or
by the way it does seem he has an empty
folder but there may be notes written in
directly on the envelope um
to say that an in-person vote is more
reliable than a mailing vote
that can mean for the person casting the
vote in terms of confidence it will be
counted
that that could mean any number of
different things
to say it applies in a particular way to
this election is crazy
and is facilitated by male voting
there are others male voting not female
supreme court case that
cases that make that same opinion so
having decided to go to mail voting
pushed very hard by these guys are the i
you would think these guys would
exclusively want
male voting that seems to be their thing
democrats
uh there had to be built in some very
very strong guarantees
that nothing would be done uh that would
that would
compromise the vote so the major
major issue the major device that was
placed there
is observation which follows on what
happens with absentee ballots
for years when you examine absentee
ballots it's almost routine
there are three people at least there
the counter
a republican and a democrat each one is
opened
envelope is looked at you check the
outer envelope which is the
envelope that provides really the
security because that's the one
oh my god that's not anonymous it has
the name the address
voter identification other things that
are in dish elements reliability we need
indicia
i that i agree with if we don't have
indicia we have nothing
you can check that against a voting roll
and once that is okay
both sides agree you open it up
the ballot now virtually becomes
anonymous or should
and then assuming there's nothing wrong
with the inner envelope
every once in a while there is usually
not then you place that in the
understand guys so so remember the
number of ballots they don't want
counted would have no
impact on who won the state like it's
it's a crazy thing that he's doing
let's skip ahead first of all i want to
see if he does another cigar ad
he does okay let's take a look at that
are not yet specified
but they were significant this would be
a good time to take a short break
if you want a good cigar go to a good
cigar shop
right you want the best go to famous
smoke shop
let famous smoke deliver your favorite
cigars
right to your doorstep at america's
lowest prices
famous opened in 1939 as a small shop in
new york city
today imagine encouraging smoking okay
let's go back now to the meat of this
whole thing
should be overturned this vote should be
overturned is will well passed a mark
in the small margin of victory and we
have a very very highly circumstantial
situation
that he was behind biden was by 700 000
votes and we can count 630 000
that will put in unlawfully oh my god so
that's completely untrue
i i think they're talking about i'm not
even going to say the number of ballots
but
the point is the the you have to
actually look at what's happening in
court
and what's happening in court even if
you
grant it would not overturn the results
in pennsylvania
sounds like a pretty close pretty close
uh uh equation of the two things doesn't
it uh worse than that
you'd say well this only happened in
philadelphia which is the capital of
voter fraud i mean philadelphia has
a 60-year history of voter fraud
recently
a conviction of several officials
obviously since his since there's such a
history of voter fraud in philadelphia
it's where you would
go in order to do more voter fraud
anybody knows that
for voter fraud i mean just as a matter
of interest
joe frazier the former heavyweight champ
has voted in philadelphia after he died
uh the grandfather of the actor will
smith has voted in philadelphia before i
don't know about any of those things
these are really common names i don't
know if it's just other people with
their names
it you know for all i know someone named
joe frazier really did go to vote
but there was a mix-up and they voted as
a different joe phrase
like you know each of the you have these
you have to research every single one of
these things
let's skip ahead a little bit and just
do um the tiniest bit more here
a couple more ballots needed so we can
catch up on on trump
what do you say you decide and then
these ballots
in complete violation of the law of
secrecy of voting
are left out on the street wide open
that's the way crooks handle ballots
that's the way professional
voter theme the other thing is you know
if those ballots were mishandled
it doesn't indicate that they were
mishandled in a way that was detrimental
to trump you know i mean it's like it's
it's just so leading in a completely
factless way thieves
handle it and they had to do in this
case uh because
they had to make up big numbers quickly
bigger than they thought
you know the democrats were planning for
this but they weren't planning for
eight hundred thousand ahead in in in
pennsylvania
that we we kind of were in the sense
that we've we believed that there could
be a red mirage scenario and there was
they weren't planted on a five percent
lead in michigan and a
nine percent lead in wisconsin a lot of
cheating had to be done
and the mail ballots gave him the
opportunity to do it now
what i just showed you leads to a very
very important incident
how many people watch which we have a
lot wow
three affidavits for people are there
and one statement from a person who's a
whistleblower
who is still nervous about coming
forward very nervous here's the
evidence that would be presented in
court at least by the three who already
under oath
somewhere around 4 or 4 30 in the
morning when a whole shift was changing
a whole group of ballots came in
amounting to something close to a
hundred thousand
were brought in in the middle of the
night through the back door not the
normal door they came in
ballots that looked and were um
and were packaged similar to
all right god this is just too stupid i
mean we i i can't subject you guys to
any more of this but i appreciate you
taking a look at
you know a little bit of it with with me
but it is completely and
and totally bizarre stuff um
okay uh all right yeah i will i will
take a couple of calls it does not seem
as though we're necessarily going to
hear from the trump administration today
i will take a couple of calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let me get updated numbers we do
now have an additional 17 members who
signed up at joinedpakman.com
which puts us at 64. that's
that's a pretty solid number i'm not
gonna lie
um and then we got another three as far
as twitch is concerned putting us up to
67.
i love it but i just want to hear from
some of you guys so we're going to
do away with the normal formalities here
if you would like to talk to me you can
go to davidpakman.com
discord and get into the waiting lobby
make sure to change your nickname
to location colon name
any fake names or fake locations i guess
location i wouldn't know
will immediately get you disqualified we
just we just don't do that we don't deal
with that that's not the way we do it
um let me first go to oh let me go to
somebody from
from my birth country let me go to
federico
from argentina federico hello
hello there david come with us how you
doing
do you want to do it in english or
spanish it's uh
how do you if you want to do english
let's do english so i don't have to
translate for the audience
okay so we were talking in on this card
with the regulars
in here and i came up with something i
can
to everybody to write down some
predictions for the next two months
and i can tell you my prediction and
maybe we can get yours okay
okay so my prediction was the electoral
results are certified
306 for biden the rest for jump
the counts are like the recounts are
started on the on the state that qualify
for it but nothing changes
maybe like 300 votes that's about it
yeah
and well trump never
accepts the results and locks himself in
the oval office for
two months or so and
three days after the
three days before by then assumes the
presidency
yes to avoid getting dragged out of the
of the office he being humiliated which
is really bad for
his tv show i guess
that's what i i think he's going to do
he resigns and gets a presidential
person from pence
what do you think you know i basically
agree with everything you're saying
except i am very skeptical skeptical
about the resignation and the pardon
from pence that's the only part i doubt
i don't i think it's conceivable but i
don't think it's likely
what what percentage will you we'll say
like that that's like
50 50 i think that the president that
the resignation and pardon
i would assign it like a 10 chance
okay so what do what do you think like
what will be your prediction exactly
yours other than the resignation and
pardon
okay so okay that's it
that's it that's it oh okay
all right very good listen is there any
new kind of
empanada that's popular now in argentina
that i might not have heard of
no not really nothing new no you you
have to stick to the classics
what's the what's your favorite though
um
with or without raisins with raisins
with raisins that's what that's from
salta right
yeah but i'm not there okay i know you
can still get it but that's the style
from salt is that right
yeah i i guess they they go for that and
like
actually they put um
sugar um that i'm not sure of that
i mean i don't know about sugar well let
me ask you this um
fried or oven baked do you prefer
i like the taste i prefer uh
fry oh no
yeah oh no what sets apart what
what sets apart the argentinian empanada
from
all of these other empanadas is that you
you bake it instead of frying it you
have to go baked
oh yeah for sure for sure okay
i'm with you okay excellent okay uh
thank you so much mucha gracias
there we go there we go uh beautiful
phone call
beautiful phone call from uh argentina
there
perfect phone call i would even say
let's go
next where are we going next
there's just so many uh people trying to
get on
and i want to be i want to have all
sorts of diversity
diversity from all standpoints
let's try um
oh this is interesting let's go to oh my
god that
people are bailing as i'm about to go to
them
hold on let's go to isidore
from tucson arizona
uh hey israel uh sorry hey david can
hear me yes i can
awesome uh this is israel from two
centers and i've been a big fan of the
show for a long time i recently became a
member on your website it's
beautiful that's the exact right thing
to do
and sorry uh but i want to be brief as
i'm torn between two questions so i'd
love for you to tell me which one you'd
rather
address one on foreign policy and one
about trump's legacy
uh give me the legacy since we're kind
of i feel like
it makes sense to wrap that before we
get into foreign policy
all right yeah so regarding trump's
legacy uh as an example and i'll be
brief but
even nixon when shown evidence of
election meddling in by his campaign
staff
when more people voted for jfk in
certain counties and swing states like
illinois and texas
nixon refused to pursue the lead he said
he didn't want recounts he said that he
didn't want the american people to hold
any doubt in their minds over who their
rightful president
would be his quote was our country
cannot afford the agony of a
constitutional crisis
sure nixon a guy who went on to be one
of our most corrupt presidents or at
least one of the most corrupt who
have ever been caught yeah and even he
had the integrity to concede but now
trump isn't and he has nowhere near as
much as evidence of voter fraud as nixon
in fact he has no evidence at all
how do you think this will affect his
legacy and how are we going to convince
his millions of brainwashed followers to
have faith in american democracy again
the second part i don't know the first
part is
it's a disaster for his legacy and what
you what you have to understand is
nixon was horribly corrupt
but you can't say nixon was stupid and
you can't say nixon didn't
i hate to use this term because it's so
fraught but
nixon loved the united states to the and
i know it's so
dicey to even say that but nixon
to some extent actually wanted to try
to do what he thought was best for the
country you know he was like an ends
justify the means type of guy
i completely disagree with him i think
what he did was disastrous for the
country
i think he was an anti-semite i think he
was wrong on foreign paul you know all
this
different stuff but he
still and i'm kind of cringing by even
saying it but
he liked the country in a way that
donald trump doesn't give a [ __ ] about
the united states
and so i think that that's a key
difference between the two
anyway uh that's it so uh thanks for
taking my call goodbye
oh my god okay very good at some kind of
voice modulation there
uh i do like that i'm i'm being told by
people that was weird that trump called
into newsmax so let me check that out if
if that's true
i do want to listen to that um
did trump call into newsmax he seemed to
be happy about
oh he called the newsmax ceo
is what seems to have happened let's
listen to that newsmax tv mr christopher
reddy
mr reddy i understand you just spoke
with the president of the united states
what can you tell us
well we had a really good phone call
this afternoon chris uh the president
called me from the oval office
called uh this afternoon and the first
thing he said i want to congratulate
newsmax on your incredible ratings
he said i've been watching newsmax but
i've also been seeing the data on the
ratings
he pointed out on some of our shows
we've gone over seven hundred thousand
per minute viewers
are they even on t like is newsmax even
on television
and uh he he said he thought it was
terrific
and that uh people and he knows he was
quite critical of fox news
if you're newsmax right now you're
loving this right like you're just it's
like
trump's just help trump's going down
but it sounds like he's going to help
you anyway
everybody's telling me that uh i'm
turning off fox and going to newsmax
and i thought it was a great uh
compliment to the work that you're doing
perfect phone call on the newsmax team
that even the president's noticed and
that it's getting so widespread guys the
president's noticed that you guys are
the only sycophants left supporting him
that's all that the president has
noticed
all right let's do another couple phone
calls here
um let me go to lana
de candidae i don't know what if this is
the name and what is location but is it
is it lana am i right
uh yes yes okay so what what's your name
and what's your location let's see if we
can clear that up
you don't know okay all right very good
that that very strange strange stuff
there
um let's go next to stacy
from the united kingdom stacy from the
uk
stacy hello
hello
how are you good how are you
i'm very good thank you i'm actually an
american living in the uk so it's a
different um set of news over here than
it is and
you you do keep me sane for all this
watching
how everything that's going on
interesting stacy have you picked up
like
is is that like an a 10 british accent
you've picked up
possibly oh maybe 20 percent
yeah i've been i've lived here for 21
years fair enough well what can i do for
you today
um i think you might have already
answered it earlier but it was just
around the um
pump going into you know his own news
channel or his own um
i don't want to say it um podcasting
yeah um what what do you what would you
what would you pin is a good name of a
show
for him to host presidency
oh my god i don't know plasma hour um
perfect half hour show i have no idea i
mean i
i really don't know what uh winning
winning winning with donald trump or
something like that
people are saying the orange hour um
i don't know that's a trigger warning
yeah maybe trigger warning
um beyond the hair i like that's
interesting
um i don't know we'd i'd have to think
on that for a little bit
okay well that's all i have really had
to say i just want to say again thank
you for
all you do you're just fantastic my
pleasure what are you in
london or where where are you
i'm in the west country west country wow
that sounds
sounds scenic it's wheelchair
oh wheelchair okay very good or as you
america
yeah all right stacy very good we have a
bit of a delay
i'm going to let you go but i really do
appreciate you calling in
let's go next to cody from virginia cody
from virginia you're on the air
hey david how you doing i'm doing well
um i just came here for
to tell you a story if that's okay oh my
goodness okay let's see i'm
i'm mildly curious so far let's see
so um i do a stream um and a youtube
stream
uh i have a youtube channel and last
night i did this um
segment where i went on to reddit the
right wing i'd
read it post it come on to my stream
ask a lefty anything it's basically what
it was okay
and um i got two people to come on and
we had
very productive conversations um
one of which i got them to agree
that uh joe biden's um immigration
policy
was probably the best policy for america
which is very interesting
um okay and also i got them to agree
that uh what donald trump did
when he was trying to uh
um uh waive uh protections for gay
people trying to adopt in south carolina
yeah i got them to agree that that was
wrong beautiful um i just
yeah i just wanted to uh tell that
little story of hope that uh some of
these people can be reached uh with the
right
rhetoric with the right um facts if they
even care about facts
some of them certainly don't that's
great now let me ask you this how long
did it take you to do that how long was
this conversation
i think we talked in total for like
three hours
okay so you see the problem with this as
a wholesale
strategy right yeah well it it
it was like probably 30 minutes before i
actually got to the immigration thing
maybe so two and a half hours we could
say
yeah yeah one of them was like way deep
into conspiracy
theory though it was like deep state um
china's taking over america stuff i i
didn't even like touch any of that
because
yeah yeah no that's dangerous stuff all
right well very interesting i mean i
think we know what we're up against at
least
yeah yep all right my friend thank you
very much great to hear from you that's
that's quite a situation for sure
um let's go next to ronald reagan
calling from the state of washington
ronald reagan you're on the air
hey david how are you good how are you
you're coming through crystal clear
today
yeah i mean it's amazing what what
you've managed to put together
over here um hey i wanted to you
mentioned something about your dad
writing something about magical thinking
in the trump world
yeah and i wanted to share a little bit
about my background
as a former mormon or a foreman and
a lot of the parallels that i see with
my former life
in people in trump world um
at least one thing that that i think is
kind of important
and that's the um reflexive rejection
of information so in the
in the mormon world they have a term
called anti-mormon material
or literature which is a catch-all for
anything that's critical of the church
i'm guessing that's similar to in
scientology this sort of idea of
suppressive people and materials
yeah that's exactly right and it's fake
news right so
trumpism has uh fake news and i remember
when i was going through my uh so-called
faith crisis i would bring things up to
my roommates at byu
about hey you know i read this thing
um at the library uh from from a primary
source
and without knowing anything about it
they were able to just tell me
that that's anti-mormon like right those
are those are lies told by
evangelical churches who are trying to
you know destroy mormonism or whatever
sure and um the same thing happens
i called the local talk radio um i call
them all the time
um i call them even more than i call you
if you can believe it
um and if i bring up something and they
ask
where i read it if i say it's like from
the washington post or the new york
times then they automatically know
that it's completely fake news
they believe that they don't know it
they believe it
right well they just know yeah they
don't even they don't need to read it
they don't need to know anything else
yeah and um it's a very hard bubble
to pierce as the last caller was
mentioning
i think that the best thing that people
can do
is just constantly be educating uh
friends and family about checking
sources
and and the the problem with um
things like uh facebook or
people learning about you know getting
their news from
social media basically which is a major
problem
very well said um are you are you still
there reagan
he just disappeared what on earth raygun
is gone
and it was like right when he finished
speaking that's very strange
uh okay all right well i hope sam cedar
is okay with him calling in i don't know
but that was that was just
bizarre just bailed um okay
let's go next where are we going next
i was liking i had questions from hit
for him from for him like for example
did
sam approve that phone call but we
didn't uh
we just didn't get to it it's too bad
all right
let's pick up on somebody else here
let's go to
son from china son from china you're on
the air
yes how are you hi how are you doing
david
good where are you calling from in china
uh i'm
i just say i just gonna tell you i'm on
a west coast i'm actually
chinese international student oh you're
in you're in the united states right now
though
yeah i've been living the state for like
last eight years oh okay
i'm i'm currently working tech industry
so
yeah first of all i just want to
congratulate like you guys save your
democracy for at least next four years
yes it it will at least now continue to
hang by a threat as opposed to
being cut but i also want to remind you
guys what the
freaking mess you guys are still in oh
you don't need to remind me but yeah
okay
and internationally i mean you know more
uh than than i do
about what's going to happen
domestically because uh republic oh
democrats didn't win the senate right
well we don't know yet we don't know yet
but it's it's
looking you know it'll be difficult it's
possible but it'll be difficult
yeah so so by then probably will be
impossible for biden to actually have
the mandate of the government
which means you're probably gonna waste
another four years
well let's hope it's no more than two
let's son let's hope let's be let's take
it a step at a time
we could we've got two senate races and
let's see how those go
if they don't go well then we've got you
know 2022 the midterms and then we'll
see then
it will be less terrible than trump
definitely but absolutely
it's still going to be a very difficult
situation i agree and i
i really worry that if fighting cannot
actually make any difference
i think in 2024 republican gonna take
over over again
well let's again you're skipping many
steps ahead
but biden will make a difference because
a lot of the disasters trump did by
executive order joe biden will undo by
executive order so
i disagree with you that biden will make
no difference i surely hope so
yeah yeah i really hope americans gonna
do well in the next four years and but i
also want to remind you guys
how much damage trump has done
internationally how much ground
charm has given in asia last four years
yeah basically
american influence is basically
non-existent in asia right now
yeah you're right which is
super terrible for our own
like development because i think uh at
least when i was growing up i always
look up to american
right i think our society will
eventually gradually become more and
more democratic
but like what trump showed like the
world last four years
i think for the next like one generation
two generation
people will be uh scared to actually go
for that direction because
for them that means if uh if we go that
direction probably we're gonna have more
chaos
yes so that's why you were damaging to
both americans and to chinese people i
think
you are completely right in your
assessment i'm curious what part of
china are you originally from
oh i'm from somewhere in the south so
it's kind of like alabama in china so is
it is it rural or
was it a city it was a city but it was
not like a huge city
i see and what do you miss the most
about living in china
uh i mean the food i guess
yeah what's the what's the particular
what's the particular dish
that you can't get in in california or
wherever you're on the west coast
that you like so many there's so many
give me one i probably haven't heard of
i i probably only know their name in
chinese so
i you probably wouldn't understand what
it is well you could describe it to me
what what is the dish what is in the
dish
oh it's kind of noodles made from rice
rice noodles okay that's a lot of dishes
i guess
yeah i actually won't intend to talk to
talk about moisture stuff like i
i want to remind americans how what a
shitty situation you guys seen and you
guys yeah but you did that
now i want to hear about rice noodles
well it was really spicy it was really
good but
uh guys we were like the word is
look look upon you guys you guys really
need to
do better yeah we do no i apologize
yeah get rid of yourself this this crazy
conservatism is like
it's poisonous love it by the way where
are you calling from right now
i'm in california i work in the tax
industry no but i mean literally where
are you are you at a restaurant are you
at a cafe
uh i don't want to tell you because my
family is in china so i don't want a
trans government to find out i'm like
talking to someone uh
progressive radio or something like no i
just mean are you out somewhere
i just hear noise in the background i'm
curious where you are it's not a trick
question
oh okay i'm near a highway so it's i'm
in the office
you're near the highway okay very good
all right i appreciate the call thank
you so much
um very interesting calls today i have
to tell you
uh a lot of different things um
a lot of different things going on let's
go next to beverly
from atlanta beverly from atlanta you're
on the air
beverly from atlanta you're on the air
beverly from atlanta you're on the air
all right barry that's too bad i was
looking forward to speaking to
beverly from atlanta let's see
um who else we might be able to speak to
here
it's interesting the different tricks
people try for me to call on them
it's really kind of random i mean it's
just there's so many people holding that
it's difficult let's go next to the
country of chile
and speak to martin
how are you david do you listen to me
i hear you um
i just wanted to ask sorry for my
english i it doesn't
come from an english speaking country
um but my ques my question is
what what do you think will be the cost
to the world
in the trump administration that had
like
four years uh it's you know
i don't think we'll know the full cost
until it's over but
the cost in terms of the damage to the
climate is significant
and again how do you measure it i don't
know but we've lost four years on
climate
the cost in terms of our alliances and
and relationships with countries we'll
know what the cost is once we figure out
if they can be repaired quickly
right and we just we just don't know
that yet you know right it's people in
the chatter saying do you have five
hours for me to explain it
um it the costs are going to be huge um
lost time on health care i mean what's
the what's the cost
in terms of loss of life how many people
died who didn't have to because of trump
policy on coronavirus
the cost is huge i don't even know how
you start to measure it
and also i wanted to ask um
what this election shows for to the
world for my
for my personal view it's like um
people in united states it's very
um i don't know how it yeah it's
polarized
um and like half of the country
thinks in a very in a way
that is like way of the whole world
what do you have to say about that
you're completely right it's like on so
many issues you've got
essentially the entire world and the
american left
and then you've got republicans who are
by themselves
or maybe you know what's crazy is often
if you look around the world
the only people who believe certain
things are republicans and then
religious extremists in places like
saudi arabia
and and people you know in dictatorships
but you're
100 correct
but do you think um
this is going to stop or or it is going
to be
like more brutal in the next years
because
it is it's very clearly that
you have i i don't want to say this but
like
stupid people like
if you compare it to the whole world yes
yes the world is not
leading to that way it's like to the
opposite so
like closing the country thinking that
every immigrant is
like going to damage the society
for me being a person living in the
other side of the world
is like very it's very sad because
you are the one of the bigger economies
in the whole world and
we all depend on you so i agree and
unfortunately
i think it will get better
diplomatically with joe biden but
there are 72 million people who voted
for donald trump so i
fear that it's getting worse in a way
that's sad man it's very sad very very
sad
okay mucha gracias amigo
okay there we go chile beautiful phone
call from chile
let's take a couple more and just see
who else is um
let's see if any of our friends are
holding let's go to
elizabeth from uh hold on where was
elizabeth there
elizabeth from pittsburgh pennsylvania
what's going on elizabeth
hi can you hear me yes i can hi
um so i wanted to call to ask
about um so i go to graduate school in
pittsburgh
and richard grinnell is a faculty member
at our university
there's been a lot of inter-university
discussion
student groups trying to organize to get
him
kicked out of his senior fellow position
yeah uh
and the dean of the college
consistently responds by telling us that
you know
it's within richard's uh richard
grenell's capacity to say and do
whatever he wants
outside of his work hours but because
he's a fellow there's no
distinct work hours that he has and
we've been talking a lot amongst
ourselves about how this is part of a
larger trend where people who
behave in these just totally like
fascist ways
are getting pardoned not just um from
trump's face but that there are
you know legitimate institutions that
allow people like richard grinnell
to just do some like batshit stuff and i
wanted to get your thoughts on
on why that is why even at the you know
high level institutionalized spaces like
a
school like carnegie mellon why people
like richard grinnell are allowed to
behave the way they behave well you're
bringing up a pretty difficult topic
because on the one hand i mean it it is
true that what he does
outside of the teaching role you know i
think i've had people like when i was an
adjunct
professor at boston college uh this
woman
and i actually i forget her name now
this woman
didn't like something i tweeted and she
called boston college and said you gotta
fire this guy and they said well he's
adjunct he's not even teaching this
semester and it was kind of just a [ __ ]
show
um and and so i do think that that is
that's a bigger and more difficult topic
because it is true
i mean i find richard grinnell's views
disgusting i find
the way he's propped up the trump
administration with lies absolutely
immoral
um but that i i just i i am still
unclear about like when do you go after
people's jobs and and that type of thing
and it sounds like you're saying
why hasn't the school fired him and
should they have and you know i i don't
know i think that's a complicated thing
if uh if a crime hasn't been committed
obviously the school could say at any
time
his conduct is unbecoming of the of the
institution they could do that at any
time
um i don't know i just i just don't know
uh you know
when when what the line is on that stuff
yeah so that's uh the core discussion
happening with student groups and i
think
what where we're all at with it right
now at least the student groups that i'm
a part of
yeah i feel like because of his
anti-mask um you know behavior and and
sort of promoting not wearing masks that
like that's when it crosses into the
territory of
that would be an argument that would be
an argument yeah like listen
we can't have anybody in or off campus
in the capacity in any capacity
promoting something that is just a
public health danger that would be like
a very cl
but then the thing is they'd really have
to apply to everybody
and if some unknown adjunct for example
tweeted something similar then they'd
really have to apply it to everybody and
it's just very complicated that's the
issue
yeah that's very very complicated thank
you for taking my call
all right my pleasure great to hear from
you that is going to do it for calls
for today i really appreciate everybody
who joined me i really appreciate
everybody who signed up and contributed
in all sorts of different ways
moderators on both uh youtube and twitch
please email me specifics about what
changes i need to make
to nightbot because i heard it was a
little bit overzealous today
i will make them we will continue to
improve and i'll be back with everybody
very very soon
you